most religious people in America fully
embrace science so the the argument that
religion has some issue with science
applies to a small fraction of those who
declare that they are religious they
just happen to be a very vocal fraction
and so you get the impression that
there's more of them than there actually
is it's actually the minority of
religious people who reject science who
are feel threatened by it or or want to
sort of undo or with or restrict the
where science can go the rest you know
are just fine with science and has been
that way ever since the beginning and by
the way there's no tradition of
scientists knocking down the door of the
sunday-school door telling the preacher
what to teach so there's no tradition of
scientists picketing outside of churches
nor should there be some emergent
tradition of religious fundamentalists
trying to change the curriculum in the
science classroom there been there's
been a happy coexistence for centuries
and for that to change now would be
would be unfortunate because I've seen
this happen in other nations in other
states where the consequences are that
you just basically recede back to the
cave because that's where you land when
you undermine the scientific and
technological innovations that come
about when you're properly chained
trained scientist or technologist
consider it also that in America 40% of
American scientists are religious so
this notion that there's some that if
you're scientist you're an atheist or if
you're religious you're not a scientist
that's just empirically false it's an
empirically false statement and what I
mean by religious is you can pose the
question in a way that is unambiguous
you don't ask well do you go to church
every Sunday because plenty of people go
to church like just for the pie you know
or the social scene after after the
service you ask people do you pray to a
personal God if you say yes to that
you're religious by prep by presumably
anybody standards of your of your of
your conduct and it's the yes to that
question that applies to 40% of
scientist so while there plenty of
atheists who are scientists or not
scientists to paint this as some
built-in conflict is there may be a
conflict but many plenty of people in
this country coexist in both worlds